nos quedamos en el problema número 13 en
el problema número 13 y estamos en el
examen número 7 en la sección número 5 y
este problema dice lo siguiente si 4x
esto es igual a 61 y esto es igual a 5
bm y esto es igual a 7 veces w
y tanto x como como ve como w son
mayores que 0 ok lo que me preguntan es
cómo podemos ordenar de menor a mayor
los valores de x o b&w ok y para esto lo
que quiero que veas es a que 4x es igual
a 6 veces 1 que es igual a 5 veces b que
es igual a 7 veces w es más pero vamos a
acomodar 2 para que estén todos los
coeficientes de mayor a menor entonces
me quedaría siete veces w es igual a
seis veces que es igual a 5 veces b que
es igual a 4 veces
ok ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que si yo me fijo en w y me fijo en x
quien es más grande bueno con 7 veces lo
que vale w hacemos exactamente lo mismo
que cuatro veces lo que vale x si te das
cuenta x es más grande que w porque
necesitamos solamente 4 de x para que se
hagan 7 de w por lo tanto en este caso
podemos decir que x es más grande que w
y por el mismo razonamiento pasaría con
p y x como necesitamos solamente 4 de x
para tener 5 debe de v
entonces a ips sería más pequeño que x y
de igual manera para 1 y entonces
podremos comparar wv así todos pero creo
que ya me agarraste la onda en este caso
como x es el más grande entonces me
quedaría que si lo vemos de mayor a
menor x es el más grande ok y antes de x
pues estaría
estaría bien porque es más grande que un
wv por la misma razón necesitamos menos
veces v para hacer las mismas cantidades
dvd w y entonces esto a su vez sería más
grande que uno y por la misma razón esto
a su vez sería más grande que doble y
por lo tanto w es más pequeño le sigue a
v y x y bueno también hay otra forma de
verlo la otra forma de ver lo mismo
sería dividiendo todo entre 4 y después
entre 5 después de 36 pero creo que seas
un poco complicado servido todo entre 4
este 4 y es de 4 seguiría pero aquí me
quedarían cinco cuartos y x6 cuartos x
siete cuartos pero creo que este se ve
un poco más engorroso a mí creo que es
mucho mejor a pensar quién es mayor
entre x ipem que son los números
extremos y darnos cuenta que x es más
grande que w porque a necesitamos menos
de x para hacer lo mismo con w ok un
problema número 14 dice
definimos la función htm como la función
2 porte cúbica menos 3 ok y además me
dicen que en el caso de que h dt sea
igual a menos 60 entonces lo que me
preguntan es que en este caso cuanto
vale 2 - 3 de ok bastante interesante
que se me ocurrió bueno yo sé que para
una cierta tm hd es igual a menos 60
entonces vamos a verlo a menos 60 tiene
que ser igual
utilizando esta función a 2 x de kubica
menos 3 y de aquí vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar dos menos tres t
aunque creo que no creo que de aquí lo
más fácil es primero despejará tema y
después calcular 2 - 3 t a ver veamos
así aquí / estos sí aquí divido entre 2
esta parte de la ecuación me va a quedar
que menos 30 es igual a de kubica menos
3 ok y si ahora sumó 3 damos lado de
esta ecuación me va a quedar que a menos
27 es igual a t kubica o eso está
bastante interesante que el número x sí
mismo es igual
y el número x sí mismo tres veces a meta
27 menos 27 o mejor aún pensando si cuál
es la raíz cúbica de 27 bueno la raíz
cúbica de 27 es 33 por 39 por 32 27 pero
entonces cuál es la raíz cúbica de menos
27 bueno pues la respuesta es menos 3
y tú lo puedes visualizar así menos 3 x
menos 3 por menos 3 esto es lo mismo que
menos por menos más por menos menos 3 x
39 por 327 de lujo ahí está entonces la
raíz cúbica de menos 27 es decir el
valor de t t es igual a menos 3 muy bien
ya que obtuve el valor de t qué te
parece si lo sustituimos aquí
encontramos la respuesta
cuando sería dos menos tres t bueno pues
si sucede lo mismo que dos menos tres -3
y esto es lo mismo que dos menos por
menos es más 3 por 3 39 y esto es lo
mismo que 11 de lujo la respuesta es 11
que por cierto es el inciso b es el
inciso b y la respuesta de éste era el
inciso de el inciso de que me dice que w
es menor que y que es menor que b que es
menor que x de lujo problema de 113
problema número 14 voy a borrar todo
esto y vamos ser el problema número 15
el problema número 15 y bueno mi cerebro
está un poco frito por estos problemas
de 7 pero sé que se terminó todos estos
problemas entonces podré dejar este
material a todos los alumnos que quieran
aprender los problemas del este para
toda la eternidad y entre ellos estarán
mis hijos y mis nietos mis bisnietos y
todas las generaciones y creo que es un
gran aporte ok pero bueno pensamos en el
problema número 15 dice si x es
divisible entre 3 x es divisible entre 3
que es divisible entre 5 y que es
divisible en 35 cuando siguiente
sencillo será divisible entre 15 ok
bastante interesante am como podemos ver
esto bueno si x es divisible entre 3 voy
a ponerlo aquí x es divisible entre 3
eso quiere decir a utilizando teoría de
números o utilizando la definición de
divisibilidad que x se ve como 3 por un
número entero un número entero llamado k
le voy a poner ok y por otra parte si es
divisible sí que es divisible entre 5
eso quiere decir que allí lo podemos ver
déjame utilizar otro color allí lo
podemos ver como 5 veces otro entero 5
por otro entero n
y me preguntan cuando las siguientes
afirmaciones
es cierta veamos la primera afirmación
me dice lo siguiente
es cierto que x por james es divisible
entre 15 bueno pues si sustituimos el
valor de xl ye me va a quedar que a esto
lo mismo que traes por acá que a su vez
multiplica a 5 pm a 5 pm porque estoy
utilizando lo que vale x lo que vale y
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 15 a
dejar cambio de color que 15 por acá
porque me y quien se porque a por m en
definitiva si es divisible entre 15
porque si yo divido esto entre 15 el 15
con el 15 se va y me quedaría acá por m
por lo tanto este inciso en cierto si yo
lo que quiero es que sea divisible entre
15 la multiplicación de x por lleva a
ser divisible entre 15 y bueno eso sale
porque x es divisible entre 3 y que es
divisible entre 5 ok vamos a ver qué me
dice el inciso número 2 el season número
2 me dice lo siguiente a será divisible
entre 15 3 x 3
5 y bueno pues esto es lo mismo que y
qué te parece si hacemos lo mismo voy a
sustituir 3 que multiplica a x pero x
vale 3 cam 3 x 3 acá ya esto le voy a
sumar le voy a sumar 5 que multiplica
allí pero que vale 5 m ok a esto lo voy
a multiplicar por 5 m y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 9 k9k más 25 m
y esto no es divisible entre 15 no
forzosamente es de excelente 15 podría
ser que sí pero no precisamente para
todos los casos es divisible entre 15 si
acá vale 1 y m vale 1 lo quedarían nueve
más 25 los cuales 34 y no es divisible
entre 15 ok entonces este este inciso o
esta afirmación número 2 no es
mi respuesta problema número 3 o más
bien a inciso número 3 afirmación número
3 5 x 5 x a esto le voy a sumar 3 esto
cuánto es pues es 5 por lo que vale x
pero x vale 3 veces acá a por 3 acá ok
ya esto le voy a sumar esto lo voy a
sumar 3 por lo que vale james pero vale
a 5m 5m y esto va a ser igual a a 5 por
3 15 15 acá más tres puntos 15 15 m o
dicho otra manera esto es exactamente lo
mismo que quien sé que multiplica a m
más acá acá más m ok que estoy viendo
aquí que este número si es divisible
entre 15 porque si yo he vivido esto
entre 15 el 15 con el 15 se va y me
queda solamente m más acá por lo tanto
esta expresión de aquí si es divisible
entre 15 y eso quiere decir que esta
expresión de aquí si es divisible entre
15 ahora si todo esto de acá y m y verá
x de esta forma y verá que de esta forma
se te hace muy abstracto amistades
podrías darle un valor a equis y un
valor ayer quiero un número que sea
divisible entre 3 bueno pues que te
parece si decimos mejor que x valga 3
quiero un número que sea difícil entre 5
bueno pues que te parece si decimos que
lleva las 5 ok si x vale 3 y lleva les 5
estaríamos viendo un caso particular de
este problema vamos a ver que me
quedaría x por james x porque sería lo
mismo que 15 y 15 es divisible entre 15
entonces este si funciona 3 x 5 james
esto me quedaría 9 + 25 lo cual ya vimos
que es 34 y 34 no es divisible entre 15
y en este caso tenía 5 x es decir 15 más
3 por 5 lo cual es 15 y esto me daría 30
y 36 división entre 15 entonces me
funcionaría el caso 1 y el caso 3 ojo
estamos viendo un caso particular y ya
mí en lo personal no creo que sea la
mejor forma de resolver un problema
siempre entre más abstractos sepa
resolver un problema mejor lo harás
porque entenderás la forma de resolver
ese problema mediante todos sus casos
pero recuerda que el examen en seattle
es un examen contra tiempo y entonces
pues esto puede funcionar te
en algún problema o en dado caso si no
recuerdas o no puedes ver cómo lo haces
de una manera abstracta pero bueno aquí
hay dos formas de resolver el problema
número 15 que por cierto es el inciso b
la respuesta a este problema número 15
que es el inciso d volvemos la pantalla
y vamos ser el último problema de este
vídeo problema
16 dice yo tengo una figura siguiente
que parece el juego de dos ángulos
creo que no es tan difícil tengo aquí
una recta parecida a ésta
ok tengo por acá otra recta parecida a
ésta y tengo por acá otra recta parecida
a ésta ok y qué datos me dan me dicen
que este ángulo de kim vale 115 grados
éste equivale 115 grados este de aquí
vale z grados ok y esto de aquí vale 10
grados éste equivale de grados éste
equivale 7 grados y este 115 grados lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale x z
cuanto vale x z grados muy bien
pues se me ocurre se me ocurre que los
puedo meter adentro de este triángulo y
creo que eso me va a servir bastante
bueno en una primera instancia podemos
hacer un poco de ángulos este ángulo de
aquí sabemos cuánto valen estos dos
ángulos son suplementarios entonces 115
más este de aquí me tienen que dar 180
grados pero 180 grados menos 115 es lo
mismo que a 20 70 en 165 grados
65 grados es decir que 115 grados más 65
grados es lo mismo que 180 grados
perfecto entonces ya sé cuánto vale éste
de la misma manera hablando de ángulos
suplementarios este ángulo y este ángulo
son suplementarios es decir que me deben
de dar 180 grados por lo tanto este
ángulo lo puedo ver como 180 menos de
180 grados menos 10 grados porque la
suma de estos dos me deben de dar 180
grados y de una manera exactamente
puedo fijarme en este mundo de aquí a
este ángulo de aquí es lo mismo que 180
grados menos z grados ok y esto lo estoy
viendo porque quiero meter a los tres
ángulos involucrados en el triángulo
ahora recuerda que la suma de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo me da
180 grados es decir que 180 grados debe
de ser igual a 180 menos a esta parte de
aquí este de aquí ya esto lo voy a sumar
este de aquí a más
180 menos z ok ya esto le voy a sumar el
otro ángulo interno de este triángulo
más 65 grados ok y esto tiene que ser
igual a 180 porque son los ángulos que
están adentro de un triángulo y de aquí
a lo primero que puedo ver es que este
180 y este 180 se cancelan entonces me
va a quedar que menos james a 180 65 es
lo mismo que
245 6 245 más
245 menos zeta es igual y del otro lado
pues ya no me queda nada este 180 se
canceló cuando esté 180 y me queda 0 ok
y ahora am yo lo que quiero es el valor
de maceta entonces qué te parece se sumó
ye iceta de ambos lados de la ecuación
aquí voy a sumar más y en maceta y de
este lado también voy a sumar más en
maceta esto lo hago porque este saber
con éste éste se ve con éste y me queda
que ya
maceta grados es igual a
245 grados que es justo lo que quería y
es el inciso en hasta la próxima